We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two.
David P. You can call it any time.
I you know, I guess some people call it three
a.m.
You don't have to, but people do.
Here's an interesting question.
This is a show production question.
I like this.
Take a listen to this.
Hey, David, this is Stephen here, long fan
and listener member.
You have an interesting question for you here.
You've been doing this for years now, over
a decade.
New film, these videos.
Are you able to do them all in one take will
take you several times.
I know it likely varies from video to video,
but generally, generally for you, are you
able to do it in only one date?
Thanks, David.
Appreciate all of you.
And yeah, I hope this place, it has nothing
to do with how long I've been doing the show
and it does not vary video to video.
This show from the beginning has always been
a one take show.
There's no cuts, there's no edits.
It's all it's all there.
And the only exceptions were we would do a
cut is if there's a technical issue which
tends to happen more during interviews than
anything else.
There are sometimes situations during an interview
where we will lose the connection with the
guest on Skype and then we'll kind of like
reconnect and get situated and then we'll
cut it in some way.
So it appears seamless.
But yes, this is a one take show.
No insult to the people that do like the cut
up thing where it's like you film a line at
a time and cut it together with jump cuts.
That's a style.
That's not the style we do.
And remember that this started as a radio
show where you're just live.
So I from the beginning was just always thinking
of this as one take.
So, yes, the entire show is one take.
It always has been.
And I mean, I don't know, you know, you can't
predict the future 100 percent, but I can't
think of any reason why that would change
in the future.
We have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
There are so many people furious with Senator
Kirsten Sinema for her thumbs down votes on
including the minimum wage in the covid bill
in the Senate over the weekend.
We are going to talk about that.
We are going to talk about Kyrsten Sinema.
We are also going to talk about something
that we kind of previewed six months ago.
And the explanation for this is is maybe counterintuitive.
Driving was way down in twenty twenty because
of the pandemic.
A lot of people working from home, eliminating
commutes.
We know all the reasons why.
And yet traffic fatality rates went up.
Why?
We talked about some of the reasons six months
ago.
Now we have a more detailed report.
And lastly, Switzerland has voted narrowly,
but they have voted to ban face coverings
in public.
This is actually a even before the pandemic
and masking.
We talked about Switzerland and face coverings
and it was mostly of religiously related conversation.
They have moved forward with a ban on face
coverings in public.
And we are going to talk about that on the
bonus.
You get instant access to the bonus show by
becoming a member at Join Pakman Dotcom or
by becoming a patron at Patreon Dotcom Slash
David Pakman show.
And remember, Friday, March 26th, we will
have a single day, huge membership bomb with
a massive discount.
We had a disastrous February from the standpoint
of membership's, the pandemic continuing to
weigh economically on a lot of people, a lot
of people canceling February being a short
month, not that many people replacing the
cancelations.
It was our worst month in a long time.
So we are going to try to get something going.
I would love it if you took advantage of this
one day membership special Friday, March 26th.
If you want to be put on the list, very exclusive
list to be notified of the special.
Just get on our mailing list at David Pakman
Dotcom and I will see you in mere moments
on the bonus show otherwise tomorrow.
I'll see you then